in 1975 i actually took an oath
with five other gentlemen became a sworn
made member of the family
and just to show you how fortunate i am
the five guys that i took the oath with
they're all murdered later on every one
of them none of them survived
[Music]
i grew up in
brooklyn new york and
my dad john francis they called him
sonny that was kind of his nickname
was a very high profile figure in the
columbo crime family he was kind of like
the john gotti of his day i'm sure many
people have heard of john
my dad was uh just very very high
profile major target of law enforcement
you know throughout the 1960s he was uh
indicted uh charged with you know
various crimes went to trial several
times so i dealt with all of that you
know during my uh my younger age at
times getting flack in school from kids
because my dad was you know all over the
newspaper
you know your dad's a mafia dad so i'd
fight in the schoolyard stuff like that
but you know inside the house uh you
know my dad tried to keep us as a family
as best he possibly could and
uh you know but that's how it was
do you feel like with your dad he worked
in certain way pre-conditioned for the
crime you know my dad originally wanted
me to uh to go to school and be a doctor
that was his desire for me and i had no
desire to be in that life
um
but when he got a
he was convicted in a very serious crime
he got a 50-year prison sentence
and he went off to do his time when he
was 50 years old in 1970. i was a
pre-med student at hofstra university in
new york
and my dad said he was innocent he said
you know i'm innocent of this crime i'm
not a bank robber he allegedly
masterminded a nationwide string of bank
robberies
uh but he told me he was innocent
and you know with a 50-year sentence he
would die in prison if he didn't get
help so i said dad i got to help you out
i lost interest in school
joe colombo was the boss of my family
back then he kind of took me under his
wing you know mike what are you doing
going to school if you don't help your
father out he's going to die in prison
so that really impacted me and i went to
see my dad in the visiting room he was
in the penitentiary and i said dad i got
to help you out and that's when he
wanted to uh or he proposed me for
membership in in the family
can you tell me how the initiation
happened is it true that there was
actually a special italian ceremony for
that
yeah when you get uh first of all
somebody has to sponsor you or propose
you into that lifestyle you just can't
go up to somebody that's part of the
life and say hey i'd like to join you
can't do that somebody has to vouch for
you
propose you say you have what it takes
in my case it was my father
and i was 21 years old and then you go
through like a pledge period where you
have to prove yourself worthy to become
a member
for me that lasted two and a half years
or so
and you know i had to do whatever i was
told to do to prove myself worthy it
could have been something very menial
you know there's a lot of discipline in
that life a lot of authority
a lot of respect
and it could have been something very
serious you know i i never shy away from
this that life at times is very violent
you're part of the life you're part of
the violence there's no escape i always
say this the mafia cousin austria in
america survived and prospered
for well over 100 years under some very
difficult conditions you know law
enforcement and other things going on
and the reason they did that was because
of the organization because of the
structure
because there was consequences if you
violated the policies and the rules
there was one boss that was a head of a
family
and he had an underboss which was the
second in command under him and then
there was a position called consolieri
who was like an adviser to the boss
and then you had copper regimes or
captains and they were kind of the
street bosses and they were in charge of
the soldiers
and soldiers were when you just took the
oath and you just came into that life
the rank is a soldier and you can move
up or stay a soldier all the time you
know depends upon your individual
circumstance
so after about two and a half years or
so i proved myself worthy and in 1975 i
actually took an oath
with five other gentlemen became a sworn
made member of the family
and just to show you how fortunate i am
the five guys that i took the oath with
they're all murdered later on every one
of them none of them survived i'm the
only one out of that group
you've uh mentioned several times the
term made men can you explain what that
means yeah you you know you're that's
the term you're a made guy after you
take the oath after you go through your
recruit period and you've uh earned it
so to speak
then you you take an oath in a very
solemn ceremony but
once you take that oath you're a made
guy that's what they say you got
straightened out now you're a made guy
and it's uh it's a privilege you know on
the street to be uh
to take that oath and become a made guy
you know there's certain perks that come
with it but there's also consequences if
you uh if you make a mistake
the ideology behind that is you're part
of a brotherhood when i got into the
life they told me listen wherever you go
in the world people will have your back
don't ever worry about your wife your
daughter your sister your mother
nobody's ever gonna touch them or hurt
them
so it's kind of a brotherhood and for a
guy
you know it's a powerful thing to me
there was nothing more powerful than
this bond this relationship this i got
your back you got my back among men it's
a lot of guys born in you know on the
street in brooklyn chicago cities like
that they look up to guys
in that life and goes on austria mafia
it's appealing to them the organization
as a whole
can become very attractive to to people
and you know i understand it because i
was one of them i was fortunate and that
i knew how to use that life to benefit
me in business and i was very aggressive
on the street i was kind of
entrepreneurial so you know in the
united states we had tremendous control
right into the white house i mean we had
politicians that worked with us we
controlled all the unions in
america all the major unions and when
you have union control and political uh
connections you uh you control a lot in
that country we had about
750 made guys guys that actually took
the oath we had a lot of associates but
750 guys and we controlled you know
quite a bit of uh
business and other things that went on
in the new york area
new jersey you know up and down the east
coast
and
across the country there were actually
nine families in various cities so it
was uh again
a pretty big organization
what would you say was the highest point
of your crime career you know i uh
with the help of others i developed a
scheme to
defraud the government out of tax on
every gallon of gasoline
and you know it was probably one of the
biggest earning
deals that we came across since the days
of prohibition it was tremendous amount
of money at the height of my operation i
ran it for almost eight years we were
bringing in eight to ten million dollars
a week coming into our operation
and uh it was very lucrative as a result
of that i was appointed a copper regime
or captain which was very powerful
position had a number of men under me i
was working with the russian mob they
were my partners in that scheme and we
were up and down the east coast
you know from new york all the way down
to florida selling gas we're selling a
half a billion gallons of gas a month
so it was a big operation and that kind
of propelled me into you know another
level in that life
is it true that you were the highest
paid mafia
member since al capone well you know the
media vanity fair i think wrote an
article and said that i was the highest
earner in that life since the days of al
capone i mean that's what they said
that's not what i said
i don't go around measuring people's
wealth in that life but
i will tell you that you know the money
that i was generating was extremely
substantial
and unless people were involved in drugs
which i never got involved in i hate
anything to do with drugs
as a matter of fact our family didn't
get involved in drugs to any great
degree
um
i don't think anybody was bringing in
that kind of revenue i really don't i
never heard of it and i've never seen it
guys are doing okay but that was you
know we're bringing in 10 million
dollars a week i mean that's a lot of
money
and uh you know for a while it was
pretty good but it also you know made me
a major target of law enforcement
because my dad had a big name so from
the moment i entered that life i had law
enforcement all over me so it started
from day one with me when i was 21 years
old but i'd gotten arrested several
times
um
you know the
always fighting law enforcement so that
wasn't something that was strange to me
i mean it was part of my life you know
almost on a daily basis as i was
rising in the ranks and doing my stuff
but
you know one of the dangers or the
horrors of that life is that you know
you make a mistake
you don't really know it your best
friend walks you into a room you don't
walk out again and obviously you know i
spent over 20 years in that life at a
high level so you know i knew situations
like that
and it was one night when i got called
into a room i didn't know if i was going
to walk out again and it was probably
the the low point
of my time in that life and obviously
i'm here so it worked out
but it was uh it's a tough situation
when you
you know believe you're facing death
it's pretty tough and you know people
have asked me you know why didn't i cut
and run or why didn't i escape
you know it wasn't heroic on my part it
was more or less robotic i was such a
product of that life that i felt hey if
this is my time it's my time
have you ever been scared
i was scared when i walked into that
room that night i mean look um like i
said you know it was a very scary
situation when you think you're gonna go
it's it's tough but what it taught me
you know um is that i could face death
you know i tell people all the time if
you're a made member of that life
meaning you took the oath like i did and
you die of old age and you die free
you've really accomplished something
because it's a tough life to navigate
can you tell me more about what happened
in that room or not really
well yeah i mean it was it was over
money and you know there was an article
that came out that uh
said that i was becoming powerful enough
to break away from the family and start
my own family that i was bringing in you
know over a billion dollars
which wasn't there was no truth to the
article at all some reporter just made
it up
but you know i did have a big crew i did
have the russians working with me i mean
i had you know a lot going on i had a
jet plane a helicopter ride houses all
over the country so
i mean we were doing very well my whole
crew was doing well so people got that
impression but there was no truth to it
uh but it gets into people's heads you
know so the boss of my family people are
watching my father was coming out of
prison on parole so he was a powerful
guy so
people get ideas in that life it's all
about maintaining power and control and
when people think there's a threat to
that you know there's a concern
so they kind of you know walked me into
that room making me believe that maybe
they they wanted me to understand that
they were still in control
and um it was it was a scary situation
because you know people were thinking i
was making more money than i was turning
in and stuff like that but once i got
into the room and that was fine and i
was you know i i became actually i got a
little bit upset
because uh i said hey i'm bringing more
money in than you guys have ever seen
before and i'm being held
accountable like this
and i started to get a little angry and
then i realized i'm talking to the boss
you don't get angry with the boss you
know i said i'm going to walk out of
here i'd be better keep my composure but
i was mad you know after the fear when i
got into the room then i got angry but
kept my cool as usual
and walked out of the room but it was it
was an impression that was made on me
and i i didn't like it you know i said
this is not what this should be about
um
because i was loyal to the family i mean
i was doing the right thing and uh you
know you don't want to be held
accountable when you're doing the right
thing
what was the point that got you in
prison
well like i said i became a major target
of law enforcement i was indicted five
times in the state
and i went to trial five times and i was
either acquitted or dismissed in every
case i beat them all
and then i was indicted in the state of
florida on a racketeering case i was
dated in
new york on two federal racketeering
cases one brought on by rudy giuliani
i'm sure you know that name
and i went to trial on that one for
several months and i was acquitted in
that case also so i had a pretty good
record of beating them at trial
but i finally took a plea to this whole
another racketeering case it involved
tax fraud
mainly the gasoline case so i took a
plea on that because
i knew eventually i was going to go down
i mean i was too big a name i was too
big a target
and
unfortunately in new york when these
racketeering laws came in if you got
convicted on racketeering there was guys
that were getting 50 and 100 years
and i was one of the youngest guys i
would have probably gotten 200 years if
they convicted me so i realized
i was in trouble so i tried to cut my
losses
i had met a young woman that i felt very
much in love with she's now my wife of
37 years
and she was really the catalyst that
caused me to
have second thoughts about remaining in
that life and trying to get out so when
i took a plea i got a 10 year prison
sentence i had a 15 million dollar
restitution i had a jet plane and a
helicopter i had to surrender it all
as part of my forfeiture
and
i thought that was the best way to cut
my losses you know do some time in
prison give the government some money
marry this new young girl move out to
california and try to get away from the
life so that was kind of the plan
i personally lost
between legal fees uh you know money
that i surrendered to the government my
you know
close to 100 million dollars i mean uh
listen i tell everybody all the time you
know you get involved with the
government
believe me even if you win the case it's
going to cost you so much money in lost
revenue and money to legal fees to
defend yourself if you do happen to go
to prison the losses that you take you
know through that time i mean it cost me
a lot of money there's no question about
it so
the the fbi and federal government they
tried to make a cooperating witness out
of me they really wanted me to cooperate
when i walked away from the life you
know there was a contract on my life
from my boss because you're not allowed
to do that and people are upset with me
on the street my father even was was
upset with me so the government used
that they came into the prison they said
you know you're a dead man anyway
francis cooperate with us we'll put you
in the program witness protection
program but i want to do that i wasn't
looking to hurt anybody wasn't mad
anybody i just wanted out of their life
they didn't take no for an answer so
they kind of moved me around to
different prisons you know never letting
me get too comfortable
and i spent two and a half years
actually 29 months and seven days and
solitary i was in the hole
and that's a six by eight cell 24 7. and
they kept me in solitary lockdown for
quite some time so
they gave me a rough time
what did it feel like to be in solitary
confinement for such a long time
solitary is difficult uh you know i
learned through that experience we
weren't meant to be solo creatures we
were meant to be social
and a lot of guys when the lights went
out at night you heard a lot of moaning
and groaning a lot of guys did not do
well and i understood it
for me it was it was difficult no doubt
um
but i got through it you know i became a
person of faith uh you know through that
experience
and that helped me tremendously i had a
very strong determination to get home to
my wife and my little babies that were
at home
and i fought my way out of there you
know it was uh
it was tough though i don't want to let
anybody think anything different
solitary is is a very difficult
situation to navigate
so talking about your life after prison
how did you adjust to it
you know
it was a hard adjustment because i had
to leave new york i moved out to
california because i would have never
made it in new york
you walk away from that life and you
stay in new york i wouldn't blast it no
doubt
but i had to rebuild myself under some
difficult conditions i still had people
on the street upset with me i knew
people were trying to come after me so i
had to be mindful of that
and then i was like a fish out of water
for a while you know i mean i never
really had a job
the last job i had was when i was 16
years old you know working in high
school
in the summer so i always work for
myself i always had to get things going
on my own so
i have to come out in la and now start a
whole new life so it was difficult
um
you know but again i'm a pretty
determined guy i'm fairly resourceful
and uh have a head for business so we
got started it took while you know it
took took a couple of years before i
really got on my feet and uh again you
know i was fortunate and that the the
whole speaking career that started for
me was nothing i ever envisioned
but it worked out you know from the
moment i got out of prison i was sought
after to to speak with certain
organizations so i do a lot of work with
juvenile delinquents gangbangers i spent
a lot of time with prison with a lot of
kids coming into the system at a young
age
damn everybody looks at mafia cozanostra
as the biggest gang in the world and you
know to some degree we were so when i
speak to them i speak from experience i
have credibility and many of them listen
they really do and i think we were able
to save a lot of lives or redirect a lot
of lives you know as a result of of that
you know i tell them it's important who
you're accountable to in life when i was
on the street i was accountable to my
oath i was accountable to my boss as a
result i spent every day in criminal
activity you know and i ended up in
prison we as adults
created the environment that these young
people are growing up in today and it's
tough man it's tough to navigate and we
got to help them so i try to do my part
when you look back at everything you've
been through
how do you feel about your life
well you know look people ask me do i
have regrets and obviously there's
things that i did in my former life that
uh i regret now
you know there's times i think i deal
with that my wife says to me you know
there's a lot of times i'm fighting in
my sleep you know and things come back
to you because you know you see a lot
during that time it's like you know the
way soldiers who experience things in
the war when things are horrific you
know you remember them
and and you can't make up for what
you've done in the past it's done you
know i i don't do what i do to make up
for that i do what i do because as a
person of faith i believe that you know
god knows our hearts he knows our
intents we can't pull a scam on him we
can't defraud god so if we're doing the
right things um
you know it'll work out in the end you
know the the the horrible thing is i
speak to so many men when i go into
prisons i have a prison ministry they're
in their 50s and 60s and they look back
and they say mike look what i've done
with my life i spent 15 years 20 years
here i lost my wife my kids don't talk
to me and i tell them straight out the
street life is dead end you can end up
in prison or maybe dead at some point in
time i tell them straight out also in
this life we are who we hang out with
you pick the wrong crowd you hang with
the wrong crowd they're going to lead
you in the wrong direction you're going
to get in trouble
tomorrow
i'll sit at seven o'clock in the morning
go and get kennedy that was my sign-off
shotgun it was named after president
kennedy i said i want one chamber one
buck shot filled with rock salt
and the other one with the normal bug
shot and all right yeah i'm not messing
about with these people they're
dangerous i'm going to shoot